ماكينه متوقعه في الولايات المتحده قد حدث
فعلا مع قرار الاحتياطي الفيدرالي برفع
اسعار الفائده ب 50 نقطه اساس الى نطاق
يتراوح بين
4.25% و 4.5% هذه النسبه مشاهدينا تمثل
اعلى مستوى في 15 عاما ورغم تباطئ وتيره
رفع الفائده بعد السلسله من الزيادات
المتتاليه بخمس وسبعين نقطه اساس الا انا
رئيس الفيدرالي حافظ على نبرته الحذره
مؤكدا انه لا يزال هناك حاجه لمزيدا من
العمل
وبحسب ما يعرف بالضبط
توقعات الفرديه لاعضاء الفدرالي بخصوص
الفوائد من المرجح ان ترتفع الفائده
باجماله 75 نقطه اساس بنهايه العام المقبل
ليصله نطاقها المستهدف الى 5.1% لتعود
الفائده ليلا انخفاض الى اربعه فاصل واحد
100 في 2024
و3.1% في عام 2025 على الصعيد التضخم
يتوقع 1000درالي بقائه فوق معدل اثنين في
المئه المستهدف على الاقل حتى نهايه عام
2025 كما توقع الفيدرالي ان يرتفع متوسط
معدل البطاله الى 4.6% خلال العام المقبل
من ثلاثه فاصل سبعه بالمئه النسبه الحاليه
وهي زياده تتجاوز المستوى المرتبط تاريخيا
بالرقود اشار 1000 درهلي الا ان الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي قد ينمو صفر فاصل خمسه
بالمئه فقط في عام 202320 وهي النسبه
ذاتها التي تم توقعها للعام الحالي قبل ان
يرتفع النمو الى واحد فاصل سته بالمئه في
عام 2024
و1.8% في عام 2005
اعتدى يوسف
قررت اللجنه رفع اسعار الفائده بواقع نصف
في المئه الى نطاق يتراوح بين اربعه وربع
و 4.5% برنامج تخفيض الميزانيه العموميه
سيستمر في العمل كما هو مخطط له قمنا برفع
اسعار الفائده بنسبه 4:15 منذ بدايه هذا
العامه وما زال امامنا بعض الطريق سنقطعه
في رفع اسعار الفائده الى ان نصل الى
مستحدثاتنا للتضخم عند اثنين في المئه
نصف نقطه مئويه نظرا لارتباط معظم عملات
المنطقه بالدولار ولا زال تاثير رفع اسعار
الفائده بين دول الخليج المصدره للنفط في
عام 2022 محدودا حتى الان رغم ان المحللين
يتوقعون ان يكون التاثير واضحا في
المستقبل وقال جيران باول رئيس الاحتياطي
لان البنك المركزي الامريكي سيتبنى المزيد
من الرفع في سعر الفائده في عام 2023 رغم
انزلاق الاقتصاد الامريكي نحو ركودا محتمل
وبرر ذلك بان الاقتصاد سيتكبد ثمنا باهظا
اكثر اذا لم يكبح المركزي التضخم بقوه
مؤكدا ان البنك لا يفكر في اي تغيير لهدف
التضخم البالغ اثنين في المئه ولا ينوي
التفكير في القيام بذلك مستقبلا مشيرا الى
انه من السابق لاواني الحديث عن خفض البنك
لاسعار الفائده
فوق شويه
تركيزنا في الحقيقه ينصب الان على تحويل
موقف سياستنا الى موقف ينطوي على تشديد
كاف لضمان عوده التضخم الى اهدافنا
البالغه اثنين بالمئه بمرور الوقت ولا
يتعلق الامر بتخفيضات اسعار الفائده
[موسيقى]